but this guy to lose it all anyway
[Music]
thanks for stopping by I want to show
you a cartoon thanks for coming to my
house
Gareth this cartoon is called big mine
freedom make mine freedom it's about who
we are as a people it's not politics Oh
God get 1948 okay have you heard the
Alfred P sloan Foundation no you haven't
no he was associate General Motors and
kind of a Nazi sympathizer that's all I
had a lot of cars and stuff for not to
know why we need to build up so this is
a Nazis cartoon you like fascism let's
get into it this is one of a series of
film produced by these how dare they are
ting college presidents super
anti-communist guy make mine freedom
make my oh so it's like a drink and make
mine freedom yeah America is many things
to many people
that's right to a 17 year old kid it's
the malt shop on the corner this still
open this is my yeah doing that thing
hey we're hopped up on malt then we're
gonna go neck airbags front porch he's a
spitter she's fine dude mother and her
family its church on Sunday mornings
yeah and to dad
it's his favorite relaxation Wow
what you might not do its freedom to
work at the job you like get to work at
the job you want yeah exactly yeah
freedom speech security from unlawful
search or seizure wait here what what
what so that guys max well that used to
matter that's interesting that's alright
hey guys
trials are like guys obviously about to
die yeah the right to vote well these
have all been taken away these freedoms
that have made America strong that's
right
okay okay so we got our freedom but
managed you must loosen up everything
huh labor is at fault it's ruining the
country my constituents as you're
elected they got a rich guy you got a
worker there they can't tell common man
knows better yeah you have the bountiful
benefits of higher wages shorter hours
and security he's selling them bottles
of communism Satan selling those this is
docu incorporated
dr. utopia including my freedom where's
that pet children's children yeah ISM
promises to take care of me forever
ready you I'll do it I'm an idiot I'll
do it I'm dumb I'll do it I'm stupid who
are you my good man I'm a Nazi first of
all he's white like he's the lightest
yeah I'm a notary yeah what uh hi he's
the only gay picked up on our system of
free enterprise isn't perfect mmm but
before we throw it away for some
imported double-talk mm-hmm let's turn
the clock back a few years to see what
it's done for us
yeah back in the 1890s Joe Doakes was
just a guy I would like to tiptoe around
his bar one day he had my dear oh here
we go
and because he was free to dream
and tinker with an LD make big crate
whoa we invented the motor vehicle card
thing sort of I don't under he invented
the car people like this is too much
Carstens needed laughs she's got
something wrong with her bottom she's
got money coming out of it I wish I had
that problem
so I get Oh I don't sleep so good but
hey hey sure we know we support that
that's that's great
it Doakes mobile like a bad news it went
out of business depression our equators
bought more food clothing travel and
entertainment than the wages of any
other people in the world that's not
[Music]
that's nice look at the Russian guy yeah
look at the air yeah before signing up
you boys ought to try a little taste of
dr. isms formula go ahead try it
but they really pounded that is oh no oh
right so it's subtle so so if you
support if you don't support capitalism
then get a tattoo on your forehead right
a strike is what it's like living under
communism no more you know more that guy
you can be one guy on in a factory I
always kind of wanted this guy to lose
it all anyway II don't hate him Oh bro
he's getting the double handy mister I
don't take subsidies other religious
guys in a concentration camp this isn't
so bad
[Music]
he's a propaganda guy now
so that anyway that's exactly the
criticisms like look it's not for you
you don't have to dump it out right
class warfare hatred or religious wait
is he's talking about America or no no
so if we lived under communism we get
race hatred inequality how ready are you
to drink that greens oh man
because capitalism's worked see you
later doctor utopia on to the next town
of peddle ups cartoons and statues are
finally working together we owned people
for 200 years
oh just play the Fife house my bad we're
gonna have to do one more take when that
man didn't point out the reality Ian
sure is huh I mean so we've just always
had propaganda flying at us yeah I mean
even then though if you saw a cartoon
you'd be like it has to be true they put
it in a talkie cartoon you know if it's
in a talkie that's like Fox News the
cartoon that's what cartoons were
goddamned this interviews over
[Music]